[Music]
the movie starts in a futuristic
japanese society the government has
implemented a complex nationwide rule
named the red threads of science
according to this rule when a person
turns 16 they are assigned a romantic
partner by the government the partners
are chosen after extensive research
about both parties like their hobbies
habits families and so on the main aim
of the law is to encourage successful
marriages and combat increasingly low
birth rates which are threatening a lack
of manpower in japan over the years the
system has proven to be fruitful as
almost 100 of government-arranged
marriages are successful in producing
offspring and are less likely to get
divorced the only drawback of the law is
that people sometimes fall in love
before they turn 16 and do not want the
government to interfere with their love
life in such cases those who disobey the
arrangement face penalties and get less
privilege as citizens the protagonist of
the film is a cheerful high school girl
named aoe she is about to turn 16 in a
day and is super excited about finally
getting to meet the love of her life all
her friends are also thrilled for her as
they have been eagerly waiting to turn
16 for as long as they can remember
today at 12 at night aoi will get a
federal notification containing all
basic information about her chosen one
she cannot wait for the notification and
is on her feet the entire day while
returning home aoi meets her childhood
best friend yuto the girls in the school
fawn over him since he is one of the
best looking students however yuto
doesn't take any interest in them
because he is in love with aoi he has
frequently tried to confess his feelings
but has always backed off because he is
too shy he is happy being her best
friend but now that she is about to find
someone to love yuto is worried that
their friendship will fall apart as they
chat about different things yuto
teasingly mentions that she was his
first kiss the scene goes into a
flashback when the two were still in
elementary school at an annual program
yuto got the role of the prince however
aoy was assigned a wildflower she wanted
to be the princess so badly that at the
climax of the drama she pulled yuto and
kissed him they still laugh about the
incident to this day in the following
scene aoi her parents and her uncle are
having a birthday dinner at her house
even aoe's parents are excited about the
notification which is scheduled in only
a few hours aoi's parents also met
through the government program but her
uncle is still unmarried it has always
been a topic that no one likes to talk
about so aoi doesn't dig into it later
she is given a dress that she wears to
bed as time passes she gets more nervous
but then yuto gives her a call they meet
outside and he hands her a gift for her
birthday it is a penguin showpiece that
goes well with her room yuto knows
everything there is to aio like how she
touches her hair when she lies he easily
finds out that she is nervous when she
touches her hair and claims that she
isn't to calm her down they decide to
reenact how she will introduce herself
to her chosen one aoi starts talking
about herself which makes yuto feel a
range of emotions especially because she
is looking at him like she would look at
her boyfriend he cuts her off and
confesses his love taking aoy by
surprise he also tries to kiss her but
she retreats in shock yuto is
dumbfounded and can do nothing but
apologize before they can talk further
they are interrupted by aoy's match
named sokuke he introduces himself and
gives her a bouquet of flowers the man
is better than what she had imagined and
is dashingly handsome mesmerized by his
presence aoi forgets about yuto he
congratulates them and leaves right
after giving the other two some alone
time to talk aoi turns towards her
prince charming in excitement but he
names a time and place before turning
around and leaving abruptly the poor
girl questions if she is dreaming before
returning home they meet at the said
place the next day which turns out to be
a fancy restaurant we find out that
sokukei's father is the chairman of a
big hospital and sokake is supposed to
inherit the wealth and position someday
he is also looking to go to med school
he is smart and ambitious but not so big
on conversation aoi continues talking to
cut the awkwardness but a while later
sokukei stops her he pulls her outside
making her blush because of their joined
hands sokuke then asks her who yuto is
but cuts her off before she even answers
he doesn't care what kind of girl aoe is
and thinks of their relationship as a
societal formality hence even if she has
more guys she is interested in it
doesn't bother sokoke aoi tries
explaining that she is nothing like that
but sokake cuts her off again the next
day at school her friends are jealous of
her for landing a rich and hot boyfriend
aoe agrees but deep down she doesn't
know how to feel about sokake in the
following week they go on several dates
all of which ahoy doesn't enjoy sokukei
walks too fast for her doesn't talk much
and never smiles at one point aoi feels
like someone is threatening him to date
her having had enough one day she
dresses up as a supposedly rich lady who
matches his status the dress-up is over
the top but sokake doesn't comment about
it aoy again tries making conversations
but he dismisses her with simple answers
she even inquires if he has told his
friends about her but sokake thinks the
question is outrageous because he would
never do something like that aoi leaves
the restaurant after another failed date
losing hope that she will ever get along
with him then she meets yuto who advises
her to meet his parents and find out
more about him so the conversations can
be more meaningful ayo agrees and goes
to his house the very next day sokukei's
mother is kind but his father is on the
stricter side he asks aoy to behave
herself now that she is about to be a
part of their family sokukei overhears
him and burns in rage he has never liked
his father because the old man thinks he
owns his son seeing him do the same to
aoi sokuke can no longer control his
anger he stands for his girlfriend
asking his father to stay away from her
after that they walk to the bus stop
together talking about many things
sokukei apologizes for not being good
enough for her aoe in turn claims that
she hardly knows anything about him but
since he stood up for her in front of
his father she is assured that he is a
good person or maybe he just hates his
[ __ ] dad ayo's bus arrives but
sokake doesn't let her board it by
pulling her around and kissing her the
bus drives away as the two continue
kissing aoy is over the moon the next
day she thanks yuto for the advice even
though it didn't work out the way he
thought it would they refrain from
talking about his confession and engage
in other lighthearted conversations
yuto's birthday is in a few days and he
will also get to meet his assigned
partner however unlike aoe he is not too
excited when sokuke and eoi are on their
next date she brings him to a shop to
buy a scarf for yuto as a birthday gift
after that they go to an aquarium but
sokukei is not in a good mood sokake
feels that something is fishy aoe
registers that he is jealous and hugs
him because him being jealous means that
he likes her sokake smiles at her for
the first time and the two share a kiss
in the following scene aoi gives yuto
the scarf he reveals that he talked to
his chosen partner but she lives in
another part of the country so they have
decided to meet in the summer since yuto
has no plans for his birthday aoi thinks
it is a great idea if she brings him
along with her in sokake initially the
date is very awkward but the guys start
talking when yuto discovers that sokake
chose his scarf by the end of an hour
they get along pretty well but then the
two are left alone without aoi yuto asks
sokake if he knows what things aoi likes
and dislikes her mannerisms her
ambitions in life or anything that a
partner should know sokake is guilty of
never paying much attention to his
girlfriend so he has nothing to say yuto
on the other hand lists the things that
aoi likes and explains how sokake can be
a better partner for her they eventually
get into a fight and yuto leaves for the
next few days he doesn't come to school
then one night aoi finds out sokake is
moving to tokyo to a better university
he will spend the next six years there
so the two will have to be in a
long-distance relationship to avoid
living apart he suggests that they move
in together however this will only be
possible if they get married it is a
trend for 16 year olds to get married
and start a family hence aoy gives it
some thought to clear her head she goes
to her uncles the next day he talks
about his chosen partner who moved
abroad when they were still together she
never returned and is happily married to
someone in london according to him
living with the penalties is easy if you
are with the person you actually love
although scared aoi feels ready to start
the new chapter of her life in the
following scene sokake and eoi are in
tokyo attending an open campus event aoy
is bored in the lecture but seeing
sokake enjoy it makes it worth it for
her after the lecture they visit several
places eat new food and have a lot of
fun in the end sokake brings her to a
church and gives her a little cat
compartment box that she had always
wanted it brings her joy which is then
multiplied when she finds an engagement
ring inside aoi says yes and the two
start preparing for the wedding she also
informs all her friends about the
proposal but a part of her still feels
empty because of yuto's absence
elsewhere yuto gets the wedding
invitation through the mail but doesn't
react to it it is the week leading up to
the wedding and aoi has a lot of work to
do but the thought of her best friend
never leaves her mind as she misses yuto
terribly moreover she and sokake have
their first fight when he refuses to let
her talk to his parents and maintain a
good relationship with them aoi gets
that he doesn't like his father but she
wants to form a connection with his
parents on her own as well sokukei
refuses to listen and shuts her down
whenever they have a conversation about
his parents the expensive dinner dates
soon turn boring as they figure out that
they do not have many things in common
one day aoi goes to sokake's father's
hospital and talks to him about the
wedding the meeting goes seemingly well
as he has finally started to respect
boundaries while leaving the premises
aoi notices sokake walking towards his
father's office and follows him she
overhears him begging his father to
write a recommendation letter for a
friend in need it is soon revealed that
the said friend is yuto and he has a
second stage brain tumor his treatment
can only be done in an expensive
hospital in tokyo but after the
recommendation letter he will finally
get a chance to save his life in the
next scene sokukei hands yuto the papers
and asks him to not lose hope since the
chances of his survival are still high
meanwhile aoy sits alone in a park still
unable to comprehend what she heard at
the hospital since yuto doesn't want her
to know about the disease she decides to
pretend to be unaware it also makes her
realize that she loves yuto much more
than she lets on then finally comes the
day of the wedding the guests arrive at
the venue where all the preparations are
done but the bride and the groom are
late outside sokake meets aoi and
compliments her beauty he asks her what
is making her sad even though he has a
pretty good idea of what it is when she
doesn't reply he inquires if she is in
love with yuto heyo is quick to deny it
but then she touches her hair by now
sokake knows what that means he tells
aoi that her happiness is the only thing
that matters and if she feels like she
is about to be stuck in a loveless
marriage she should run away right now
he also promises to handle the guests
and the parents before encouraging her
to hurry up filled with tears aoi thanks
him and runs to the airport where yuto
is about to fly to tokyo for brain
surgery they meet at the terminal and
aoe expresses her love as yuto did on
the night of her 16th birthday initially
yuto freaks out asking her to return to
the church but in the end his dream
comes true and they share a kiss
leave a like if you're like me and
you're really glad this movie didn't end
with yuto's death
subscribe for more videos like this turn
on notifications and leave a like to
help the channel out thank you for
watching